hello hello and welcome to another
bitcoin protocol paper explained
tutorial video
in this video we're going to be
discussing the bitcoin network setup
despite the scary and ominous sounding
name this is actually a piece of cake
compared to the previous proof of work
section so you guys can all breathe easy
so with that let's go ahead and get
started so
this section starts with the steps to
run the network
are as follows one new transactions are
broadcast to all nodes
two each node collects new transactions
into a block
three each node works on finding a
difficult
proof of work for its block four when a
node finds a proof of work it broadcasts
the block to all
nodes five nodes accept the block
only if all transactions in it are valid
and not
spent already six nodes express
their acceptance of the block by working
on creating the next
block in the chain using the hash
of the accepted block as the previous
hash okay simple enough so at step one
every transaction that's done
it's just broadcast and this again is on
a best effort basis and more on that uh
at the end here
number two each node collects new
transactions into a block
sure that's just you know we're logging
all the transactions that have occurred
into the newest block
number three whilst doing number two
each node is working on finding
that proof of work for that block so
that's what we talked about in the
previous two videos is the whole proof
of work stuff
number four when a node finds the proof
of work successfully it's gonna
broadcast it's just gonna yell it out to
everybody hey i got it just one big
announcement
and again this announcement is on a best
effort basis
and again more on that shortly though we
did cover at least what that means in
the abstract
number five nodes will accept that new
block only if all the transactions
within it are valid and not pre-spent
transactions
number six acceptance of a block is
expressed by these nodes when the nodes
begin working on a new block
and basically they show their acceptance
of exactly what block they accept
because they're including the hash of
that previous block in the new block
so if you recall that big time stamp
server from like i think three videos
ago
the timestamps are hashed and each new
block contains the previous blocks hash
timestamp
which basically is including every other
previous blocks timestamp because
if you recall the order if you you know
hashed
the same input in the same order you
would
end up with the same exact hash so
that's that's basically how that
uh how that works and why that works so
you still only have one hash
but it in theory contains every other
hash
within it uh because it it it's based on
that order
of input all right so easy enough just
assume
a few simple rules to the network and
how it works and really that is
you know there are only six rules so
anyway
um back to the paper nodes always
consider
the longest chain to be the correct one
and we'll continue working on extending
that chain if two nodes broadcast
different versions
of the next block simultaneously some
nodes may receive
one and uh or the other first
in that case they work on the first one
that they received but
save the other branch in case it becomes
longer
the tie will be broken when the next
proof of work is found and one branch
becomes
longer the nodes that were working on
the other branch
will then just simply switch to the
longer one
now here is the first example of another
reason why best effort is the chosen
system
um as a rule nodes choose to accept the
longest chain because this is the chain
that clearly is the most supported by
the most
cpu power in the network since to be the
longest it simply means that
it has the most you know quote unquote
cpu votes so to speak
so in the case of two nodes yelling out
a new block at the exact same time
some nodes will get one version other
nodes would get another and they will
both work on achieving
the next block not whoever reaches the
next block
first would be the victor and the nodes
working on the other one would simply
shift over because
again at the broadcasting of a new block
the nodes would realize they were
working on a shorter
invalid chain and they would just hop
over to that new one
so back to the paper again new
transaction broadcasts do not
necessarily need to reach
all nodes as long as they reach many
nodes
they will get into the block before long
block broadcasts
are on are also tolerant of dropped
messages so if a node does not receive a
block it will request it when it
receives
the next block and realizes hey i missed
one
now again best effort is further
utilized here
this also kind of builds on the last
paragraph where simultaneously two
blocks were broadcast and the winner is
the one where the proof of work is
solved first
so if a block is just missed right if
they just somehow didn't get that
message
then that node's going to keep working
on the previous block and then once
another
block is received that node that is
behind is going to realize oops
and it's going to catch up because it's
working on the wrong chain now
so now i want to go ahead and further
break down why
best effort is used here and um
and now again best effort means in case
you skip the abstract
it's an attempt the best effort
basically means there's an attempt to do
something
but if that something doesn't occur or
it's done wrong or whatever there's no
re-attempt
there's no air reporting any of that and
everything just keeps kind of trucking
along
so the main benefit to a best effort
system
is a lot like the main benefit to the
bitcoin network itself
and also a lot of uh or it's a lot like
a type of machine learning called
an artificial neural network so
an artificial neural network is neat
because it contains a principle
known as graceful degradation so
artificial neural network
obviously is also a network uh and the
intent
and the attempt of this is to mimic the
human brain so say you have a task where
you're giving this artificial neural
network and you show it like a picture
of a small
couch let's say now some of the nodes in
the network
uh might call it like a futon or
something like that a few might call it
a bed
and many are gonna call it a chair but
most hopefully
say this is a couch so if the
artificial neural network is working
correctly couch
will have the most votes though still
many of the nodes will be incorrect
possibly even corrupt so this is why
graceful degradation is
nice and why neural networks within
logic of programs is really helpful or
just parallel programming
because normally when you have what's
called linear programming
where it's strictly like step by step
it's literally
linear it's just a line if any of the
steps along the way get messed up
somehow basically everything
fails right you either succeed or you
fail and any degree of failure results
in like
catastrophic failure but with graceful
degradation
and like networking and also what's
called parallel
programming what's used here is if
you're using like a neural network
you might have multiple tasks happening
at the same time multiple calculations
and all this
some can fail some can be wrong some can
have bugs
but as long as the majority are correct
you'll find yourself having success
now a good analogy here is like a rope
versus a chain
so in a chain if if one of the links are
broken the whole chain is
is rendered useless catastrophic failure
but with best effort or neural networks
or
parallel programming you've got
something more like a rope
where the fibers of the rope
individually can break yet the rope
itself is still successful so back to
bitcoin
with voting processing working on new
blocks it's all parallel programming
on a best effort basis so even when some
nodes
either get corrupt like either
mistakenly or purposefully
send wrong data get wrong data get no
data it really doesn't matter
the network itself is based on graceful
degradation
and it's still going to operate
correctly and securely
and this is why best effort is used and
it's there's really a whole
slew of reasons why uh it's used
so that's going to conclude the network
section of the paper
the next section we're going to cover is
incentives so stay tuned for that
uh if you guys are confused or you've
got any questions or comments or
whatever feel free to leave those below
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and the subscriptions
and until next time